says an agent asked to inspect her brain
she pulled my hair behind my head just
like started laughing and I was like
giddyup tsa says it's taking the matter
seriously and has launched an
investigation
[Music]
there's a calm surrender when you board
a play when the touch of lonely hands
can't be turned away your innate person
I'm Lebanese wearing tribal Bray that's
just my hair you always make now
machines god dang dang dang good I'm
trying to see it scan
you feel the glove
tonight yes it feels big
it ain't enough
for this their rape under the bank he's
gone too far
terrorists II people we haven't caught
one yet and though we spilled the ashes
of your Nana Ruth we neutralized the
thread government forced processions we
won't do that again
now walk right here and take off your
shoes while I giddy up your head
you feel the love
tonight
though it feels beers are
it ain't enough for us there nope I'm
just gonna drive just gonna take my car
you're weird dude
stroking my hair like a Biden
meet-and-greet